how you guys doing be scared
you guys ready I'm ready
we're going to start there might be some
muscle tension in that ear
hey Gemma you are giving up bad blood
off your bodies go to Waterloo small
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
smelly uncle ah how you guys doing we're
gonna go through a pajama session I'm
gonna go do her John and myself pajama
for those that don't know it is a really
stressed upon Sunnah it's from the last
and final mission to Prophet Muhammad
peace and blessings be upon him there
are so many hadith statements from the
Prophet Muhammad regarding hijama now
many of you maybe have familiar with the
dry cupping they missed some there I'm
sure there's benefits there in the dry
company for this wheel what cupping so
you really want to tune in to this
episode I'm gonna go through it on me
myself and they're gonna ask some
questions and hopefully you guys will be
turned out where you can make this a
part of your life so you get a better
all-around health while incorporating
this Sunnah and in helping others also
because the one who revives a Sunnah of
the Prophet SAW some will have the
reward and similar to the one who does
it
[Music]
so I might go so you're the hijama
master yeah is there like a certain name
they give for the people who do hijama a
general practitioners pajama share
practitioners alright
or he Java Mufti may be mostly JAMA
all right come on so this is a visitor
facility you guys got here yes very nice
[Music]
so you even have a assist oh the sisters
got a three times four times bigger room
come to LA come to LA modular we have
three ladies here they're doing a job
for a woman and then we give women their
complete privacy and do it completely
separate for the ladies here see so so
we have you know the men giving the men
hijama and the woman you have a hijab
woman hijama expert to give me JAMA to
the women we want to make sure that we
keep women very comfortable and give
them complete privacy but the same time
make sure that the woman that is doing
the Jama is also an expert so the the
person who does nagamma here
her name is Halima and few others she's
been doing a gentleman here for more
than five years so this is fun right yes
pin it all right there you go okay nice
and these are the cups you guys use here
and this is the for the people that I
don't know there's a little table you
sit it's people are familiar with the
dry cupping
yes this is would be considered what
what cupping yes we'll do both the dry
cupping and the wet covering and I'll
explain you the process of the boat and
what's the difference in each one of
them why would one choose to do dry
cupping versus wet cupping where is it
more popular and how it's going to be
more beneficial okay you guys ready
I am let's do it okay guys were almost
ready you got me in like this gown we're
gonna go through the hijama
don't be scared it's fear the unknown so
we're gonna do this episode and
hopefully eradicate that fear through
knowledge a little bit of this session
here me going through it I'll be the
guinea pig I've done it before and
hopefully you guys will go through it so
you know the process all right you're
not gonna be in there a knife or
anything it's very simple it's no pain
but tremendous benefits okay you ready I
am tuned Shawn
let's do it okay guys I'm on the table
we're about to start
ready you ready it's all aw all right
wonderful hungry luck so why don't I
have you do is I'm gonna have you put
your head down into this cradle and then
we're going to do a jaw noted a on your
back right a lot of the acupressure
points are on the back that's where the
points are for some of the vital organs
in the body also some of the sunna
points are also on the back so inshallah
we're going to start with that so
already you guys ready I'm ready
bismillah come on this table is pretty
comfortable it's relaxing chill as we
get started with Ujamaa one of the
things that we want to be extra careful
with is probably going to the hygiene
part of the Hazama so we want to make
sure that we scrub your body really
really well and get all kinds of dirt
and germs and bacterias out of the way
proper hygiene is one of the keys of
successful gage enema and preventing any
kind of side effects what I like to do
as a next step is put some essential
oils on the back so it gives the back a
little bit Souness before the Hazama
process starts but at the same time it
kind of soothes your muscles this oil
also acts as antiseptic antibacterial so
additional layer of hygiene additional
layer of protection on your skin
but the idea so far so good I'm doing
good tonight right now how many cups do
you typically use um typically we would
use anywhere from five cups to eleven
cups depending upon what we are treating
when we're doing the preventative hey
John look for somebody who wants to try
the Jama doesn't necessarily have any
chronic conditions I would probably do
about seven to nine cups on them in your
case we're going to start with seven
cups on key points also on tune-up
points so we're going to start with the
point right here this point is called a
CT Junction this is where the desert of
the thoracic spine and cervical spine
comes and meets so we're just going to
put a cup here doesn't hurt at all if it
does let me know all we're going to do
is give it a couple pumps one one two
and that's it you did okay with that yep
and then one more time we're going to
put a couple right here
okay
none of the things to be careful about
is that you're using their cups that are
not previously used that the cups we use
are brand new they're individually
wrapped when the patient comes in is
when you open up these cuffs so as you
can see this is a brand new cup we're
going to open right now
all right so we've got seven cups on you
brother Eddie are you feeling okay and
comfortable yep feeling great so let me
don't we just explain really quick what
we're doing right now is this is the dry
hijama or dry cupping you would the term
pajama the Arabic term hijama is more
commonly known also as the wet cupping
so a lot of time this question comes up
what is the difference between wet
cupping and dry cupping this right here
is the dry cupping all right this is
where we apply the cups on the body
without making any cuts this has a
similar effect as getting a massage done
so it releases the toxins it kind of
gives a relaxation to the muscles any
kind of muscle tension it releases that
but what it does not do is remove the
toxins so that's why we need to go into
the wet cupping or what Hazama so as you
can see if you zoom in a little bit you
can kind of see that the the texture and
the color of the skin is kind of
changing a little bit right kind of
looks like a bruise but brother Eddie
you tell us if it's hurting you at all
no no pain no pain just info all right
it just looks like the bruises are there
so what's happening is that toxic blood
is kind of collecting in that area we
use this technique of dry cupping before
wet cupping so that we don't have to
make deeper cuts we can still get away
with making shallow very small scratches
if you would not even cuts which are
shallower than paper cuts
doesn't hurt not discomfort at all and
then we get all that blood bad blood out
of that area so this is the technique we
use of dry cupping before we do the wet
coming
so here you can probably see different
coloration and texture of the skin which
indicates to me as a practitioner where
are the problem areas and where there
might be more stressed let me give you
an example so this is you know one of
the one of the cups that we have at the
base of the neck which is not as dark as
probably this point would be so you can
kind of tell that there might be some
muscle tension in that area so it just
tells us to focus in those areas a
little bit more so right now we haven't
made any cuts this is just dry cupping
so does every different spot that you
put the cup on have a different effect
100% so I will go over different spots
so this is considered a CT Junction spot
so this spot is responsible for mine and
body prophet sallallaahu they will send
them he actually had his JAMA done on
this spot right here
all right is that the CT Junction or you
can say at the base of the net these
spots right here have responsibility or
these are acupressure points for lungs
and heart then you have points that are
responsible for stomach and liver
detoxification and a little bit lower
these are the points for diabetes and
then if we did go a little bit lower
those would be the points for kidneys so
together these points gives the person
overall health benefit now it is not
necessary that somebody have lung issues
or somebody might have heart issues for
them to take advantage of this just like
your car you wouldn't wait for the
engine to fail in order to go and get
oil change
hey JAMA is best when done as a
preventative how long do you typically
leave the the cups on for the dry so for
dry cups we're going to leave it on for
about five to seven minutes that gives
us enough time from muscles to get
prepared it gives us enough time for
blood to get collected in that area and
it gives us enough
to skin to get somewhat of a numbness as
well so you don't feel the cuts as much
so not what we're going to do is we're
going to prepare for the wet cupping or
we're going to prepare for hi Gianna in
that what we're going to do is remove
these cups so now you take them all off
we're going to take all of them off
and now we're like now we're going to do
the actual process of pohjanmaa it is
very important the person who is doing
hey Jonna that they use a tool that it's
sterilized at Chicago hijama we use a
stirrer lized surgical scalpel to make
the cusps
this is individually packed never ever
reuse any tool any instrument that has
been used on somebody else always make
sure everything is used on you is brand
new here anything that touches a patient
goes straight in the garbage so we're
going to open up this sterilized scalpel
you know do they have a number on those
which would yes so this is a number 15
scalpel and the reason we use number 15
is Kapil is it makes the smallest and
shallowest cuts versus some of the other
scalpels that might use a longer blade
and make longer and deeper cuts that can
leave a scar so we have to be very
careful to do a pajama in a way that
prevents any kind of side effects but
also prevents any kind of scarring as
well so someone doesn't leave the job
with just doing the gentleman then they
got a bunch of scars on their back in
most cases you should not have scars but
some people with certain skin type might
have a very faded scar left on their
back we're typically nothing
typically nothing brother Eddie here he
hasn't had me JAMA before and I don't
know if you can zoom enough he has very
very faded lines here right in this
circle right here he has very faded
lines of scarring it is almost not
visible to naked eye but I'm kind of
making it so that you can see it so this
is kind of what is left behind after he
JAMA is done right here is what's left
behind in this circle so nothing more
than that
all right so now in chela we're going to
start the process of pohjanmaa what I
would like for you to do brother brother
auntie is for you to recertify huh
because Allah subhana WA Ta'ala has kept
chiffon in surah fatiha prophets of
Allah
I said that dear Shiva and surah fatiha
so we read surah fatiha focus on the
words of surah fatiha and mcdu are to
Allah to give you shiver hey Jana is a
spiritual process not a medical process
to make dua to Allah to make give you
Shiva because Shiva will come from Allah
subhana WA Ta'ala what you will feel is
that you'll feel like I'm writing with a
pen on your back nothing more than that
it doesn't hurt it doesn't twitch you're
not going to feel like I'm cutting your
back it doesn't even hurt as much as a
vaccine it'll hurt less than a vaccine
just like I said it will feel like I'm
writing with a pen on your back that
make sense yes
are you ready take a really deep breath
in and then exhale all the way out and
one more time really deep breath in and
then exhale all the way out and one more
time fill up your lungs all the way and
then all the way out out out out out out
up now relax and then just reach sort of
falling on make dua to Allah to give you
a fine chalo chalo mostly doesn't even
body goes in
you don't
[Music]
you're doing good
their lives
Aloma cilia dicey then I'm her Medina
Mubarak or Cindy paraphrasing the hadith
about the cure or something to do with
the cutting at the moment of when it's
cut so there is a hadith of Prophet
sallallaahu a salon where prophet
sallallaahu some said that in the cut of
hegemony Shiva that's one of the Hadees
now there has been many Hadees talking
about hey John where prophet sallallahu
wasallam has emphasized
Pajama upon his home on now with Ramadan
coming one of the things that's timely
is that the time of Islam will Mirage
when prophet Sulaiman Islam was coming
down from from the heavens the angels of
the heavens emphasise prophets of Allah
Himself saying o prophet of allah upon
your Ummah is Hashanah then there's
other Hadees as the prophets of allah
allah wa sallam saying that when
pohjanmaa is done it has benefits on
intellect
it has benefit of giving a better mental
health and has benefit of getting better
digestive health and another Hadees
prophets of allah assalamu said that do
not wait till your blood rages for you
to do Hazama kind of telling us to do
hey JAMA in a preventative way before
the problem starts arising now with
summer coming and hot weather coming
what that means with blood raging is in
the summer time your blood gets hot so
prophet sallallaahu Salam is
recommending that upon you is hijama
do hijama before your blood starts
raging Prophet sallallahu wasallam has
recommended Hashanah
for migraines prophet sallallaahu has
recommended Hazama for mental health
prophet sallallaahu Saddam has
recommended Pajama for all sort
of health issues prophet sallallaahu and
I said that out of all the things you do
as remedy the best of the remedy is
Hashanah prophets will allow some said
that I prefer there's three things that
there is there's curing there's honey
there's cauterizing and then there
hajima and then prophet sallallaahu some
says i do not prefer cauterizing so
prophet selasa was telling allah to
adopt honey and to adopt a JAMA for the
Cure so as you can see with Hashanah
process there's no cauterizing there is
this general myth that pajama equals
cauterizing because in ancient time or
maybe even in recent history people use
fire cups to durha JAMA in modern times
we use mechanical cups to do the exact
same thing another myth is that if you
do not use fire cups then you're not
doing pajama that is absolutely not true
as you can see we're we're doing all
these steps of Kijana as you would do
with fire cups brother Andy how are you
doing good
you feeling good any pain no any
discomfort no okay I come there that
you're feeling good
so as you can see here let me have this
one how much blood is typically
connected in the seven cups 11 cups how
many ounces so let me zoom in here you
can see that in different cups you have
different amounts of blood typically
you're looking at no more than you know
forty to seventy cc's of blood so it's
not a huge blood loss from these cups
and in this is this the stagnant blood
the blood that
you know what's the difference between
when you're giving blood when you're
going donate one in this life so it's a
really good question what is the
difference between donating the blood
and lymphedema
so a lot of people say that is hey John
the same as doing bloodletting or just
donating blood it's not the same and the
reason for that is when you are doing
bloodletting or when you are donating
blood you are actually giving away good
blood of your body versus when you are
doing a gentleman you are giving up bad
blood off your body that your body does
not want so what is the science behind
hey JAMA and why is this recommended
what we are doing rekha JAMA is we are
causing a controlled inflammation at sub
cuteness level so just on the skin level
not going deep we're causing a
controlled inflammation and after that
we cause a control wound what that does
to the body is starts ringing a bell in
the body saying I have inflammation here
so the anti-inflammatory properties of
the body or the chemicals of the body is
start rushing towards this area giving
the health benefit or health assistance
that that area needs then we call a
controlled wound by making those small
scratches that does a few things number
one it gets rid of the toxic blood that
is in that area number two since it is a
wound the body comes to rush to help
heal that wound and then thirdly since
there has been a loss of blood in that
area body starts producing new healthier
blood that is more rich in oxygen so
that area benefits from it the muscle
benefits from it and remember that is an
acupressure point so the vital organs
that are in that area also benefit from
head also benefit from it so in total
what you get is an overall better health
so very different from just you know
giving up blog or just donating blood
one of the other myths of Hazama is that
you are giving up a lot of blood that is
not necessary
actually hijama what done properly you
should only be taking out a small amount
of blood not a cup full or two cups full
those are not necessarily good practices
with all the respect to the people that
are doing it those are not necessarily
good practice a good practice is to take
out the amount of blood that we are
taking out and you achieve that by
making shallow cuts not long deep cuts
so you leave it on for five six minutes
with the dry cupping what about now as
what is coming out how long is it left
on so with dry cupping we leave it on
for about five to seven minutes and then
after that we give a little bit rest to
the skin and then once that has happened
we apply though we do the wet cupping
process and we leave these cup on for
about seven to 10 minutes no longer than
that that ensures that we're not going
to be too aggressive where the skin or
the muscles can't handle it when the
blood comes out why does it look like a
sort of jello so when this blood comes
out you will see that it's going to look
jello and the reason for that is it is
the toxicity in the blood that's going
to give it the texture that you're going
to see a lot of times people say that
when this blood comes out it says well
that's what blood looks like when this
blood comes out you will see the healthy
blood and you will see the unhealthy
blood that toxicity and electic acids
and some of the other things that your
body does not want it's going to be in
this blood that's what's going to give
it this this texture and the color
sometimes this blood comes out dark red
sometimes dark maroon and when this
really talks it it comes near black
almost so we'll see that and then we
also see that you will have some good
blood coming out as well so when we see
good blood coming out that's when we
stop the V gamma process how often do
you recommend people do hijab I
generally recommend people if they have
a chronic condition
I recommend them to do it every three to
four weeks for three months and then
after that they go on a quarterly
schedule the people that do not have any
condition necessarily and they want to
do it preventatively I recommend them to
do it once every two to three months is
it is there anything saying you can't or
would it be a problem if someone wanted
to do it once a week the only problem
with doing it once a week is that your
skin hasn't had enough time to rest and
heal what if you just moved it away from
that point you can yeah if you're not
doing the same point then you can do it
and the reason we can do it is because
we're not taking a whole lot of blood
out so it's okay for your body to take
some more blood out another question
comes up is that is this Hazama only for
a man or is it also for a woman so hey
gentlemen can be done for both men and
woman there's some myth out there that
this woman have menstruation they have
some blood loss and and and that's their
age Alma if you would that's not true
even though that process does take place
women still need to do pajama because we
still need to do
cupping put those cups on those
acupressure points to give them better
health I've come to learn we have
certified and licensed Hazama
practitioners where we do Hazama for a
woman in complete privacy done by those
certified and licensed ajoomma
practitioners and there's tons and tons
of benefits that people have seen doing
Hazama for a woman from fertility issues
to menstruation issues migraines back
pain shoulder pain thyroid issue
diabetes woman benefit from Hazama
immensely but the thyroid issue is a
growing epidemic how do you treat the
thyroid issue with iijima there are some
acupressure point that help regulate the
thyroid and you know we do her yama on
those points and we have seen a great
amount of success with people that have
a fibroid issue get balanced especially
a lot of people that have had you know
weight gain with it lethargic nest
luggage nests and so the other helps you
as part of the thyroid have seen great
great benefits from from very pajamas
where do you typically put the points
for the coast for thyroid
so the cuffs for thyroid you put it on
the neck right here right there yeah and
how many treatments do usually do if
someone has a thyroid issue yes so again
it's coming back and so somebody has
thyroid issue is considered chronic
illness we ask them to come every three
to four weeks for three to four months
how about the different points on we
covered from the neck down what about
when people do the hegemony on their
heads do you have to have it shaved if
you do it on your head
so hey Yama on the head is very very
beneficial a matter-of-fact prophet
sallallaahu Lewis limit setting aside
hey hobbies that do not leave out on
doing pajama on the back of the head
there's immense amount of health
benefits and mental benefits doing
Hazama on the head the point for doing
the general on the head is right here
this is the main point of doing a yama
on the head and then there's two other
points here and the number one here but
the main point is right here
you do need to shave your head because
we cannot get suction of the cup on top
of the hair and not what we're going to
do is seems like we've collected enough
amount of blood and the cup has been
sitting for some time so now we're going
to remove these cups I will try to show
you what we're collecting from this
ready yes so what we're going to do is
just put a paper towel right here this
is a brand new paper towel and make sure
we use a paper towel that is smooth on
the skin and we just if you zoom in your
camera a little bit you can kind of see
the quality of the blood that's coming
out see that right here so we're just
going to scoop that up
so these are actual toxins leaving the
body these are actual toxins we're not
just you know releasing it from muscles
and letting it linger but we're actually
removing it from the body and that's the
big difference between the dry cupping
and that's an Asian tradition but then
it goes back yes it goes back to the
Egyptian times of doing the the wet
cupping were things like massage and
some of the other methods might release
it from the muscles but does not leave
it from the body so this right here is
what I would call healthy blood we have
a little bit of that and then what we're
scooping up right here as you can see
this is the back toxic blood do we find
this kind of cupping and any other
tradition other than Islam as you can
see right here this is I mean you can
just imagine this was in your body right
here something like this sitting in your
body cannot be healthy
have you known of any scientists or
doctors who have taken this to the lab
and analyze this there are a couple
scientists that have been a couple case
studies done on Hazama and I can give
you a link for that where they have
found
Hazama to to benefit the body now one of
the common questions that come up is is
this Islamic treatment or is this phone
and other cultures too the fact of the
matter is that this was adopted by
prophet sallallahu wasallam
but it goes back to Egyptian time and
Greek times and Chinese have also
adopted it so it's not only in Islam
that this this high JAMA is found
however Islam has emphasized done a lot
with Prophet sallallahu wasallam making
numerous Hadees or sayings of the
Prophet talking about Pajama and you can
see the words of prophet sallallahu some
are so true you can see what is coming
out of the body there's no other
treatment that I know of that is going
to
take these toxins out of the body other
than giving medicine without although
all due respect to modern science and
and medicine are you talking about now
that we clarify medicine birth drugs
because are you talking about the drugs
nowadays that think that you that is
prescribed by doctors or we tell an
actual medicine so I'm talking about
healthcare in general right including
medicine and drugs yeah were some of
these some of these ailments are are are
targeted with but I do not know of any
treatment out there that physically
removes this kind of blood out of the
body nothing out there like this there's
nothing absolutely nothing out there
like this and not as effective as what
hey JAMA does in a very clean very very
low risk environment if done properly
and gives these kind of benefit then
almost I don't want to over exaggerate
an almost instantaneous way we're not
saying that you need to be doing this
for four years and years or months and
months before you going to see benefits
I have had a lot of patients that have
had chronic migraines for for years and
years to a point where they were taking
pain
shops in their head in order to get that
rid of the migraines and within two to
three treatment they're completely out
of their headache and they're not taking
they're not taking any kind of pills or
any kind of drugs anymore to to
alleviate their illnesses I had a
patient recently a young fellow probably
18 years old who came from Hazama for
arthritis and when I asked him to change
he asked his mother to come in to help
him change I said you look pretty good
why aren't you changing herself he said
I'm Arthur I did so bad and my risk that
I cannot change out on my shirt so I
have to have my mother help me he had
two or three treatments and
for two or three treatment treatments
one time I saw him at a basketball court
playing basketball and I asked him I
said you were playing basketball and he
said yes my arthritis is gone I said
well did you increase your drugs or did
you starting some shots and he said no
just Ujamaa I haven't seen my doctor in
nine months now this is not to say that
when you do a job when you stop seeing a
doctor and stop taking drugs obviously
you want to continue following the
advice of your medical healthcare
professional but this gives you an idea
that how effective the hadees' and the
treatment that was prescribed by prophet
sallallaahu salaam is now you thousand
what is the age of person good question
that's a good question that what is the
age of a person that should do hey John
hey Jenna is good for all ages
we prefer to have young adults um no
less than 16 year old to do hi JAMA so
they can kind of communicate with us if
they're feeling comfortable and how
they're feeling and I try to avoid doing
hey John lot to folks that are older or
anyway advanced in their age in a way
that their healing capabilities have
diminished as you can see that this is a
very shallow cuts that we make but
there's still a healing process that
needs to happen so if somebody who is
way advanced in their in their age is
going to have a little bit tougher time
healing from this that also brings up a
good question eyes off who is not a good
candidate for hey JAMA and who is a good
candidate pretty much everybody is a
good candidate for hey JAMA with the
exception of very few a pregnant woman
is not a good candidate for her JAMA
somebody who has heart disease in a way
that they are taking blood thinners and
their doctors cannot let them stop
taking those blood thinners they're not
good candidates for pajama somebody who
has diabetes that is not managed it is
out of control they're not good Candida
for hijama somebody who has skin rashes
or somebody who has his skin virus or
skin problem are not good candidates for
hijama
so as you can tell there's very few
cases where Kijana is not recommended or
as a contradiction for people other than
that somebody with migraine somebody
with control diabetes somebody with
blood pressure stress depression anxiety
are all very good candidates of rajamma
including man with potency issue woman
with fertility issue woman with
menstruation issue are all very good
candidates for hijama
so as you can see here now we're kind of
done with the hygienic process and this
is what he's left with I haven't touched
him yet ever since I took that cup off
so this is what he looks like before I
apply some of the oils and some of the
preventative cleansers and stuff like
that on it so this is what he looks like
these are what that custom look like
we're going to clean it up a little bit
now all right so now I've put on your
fresh set of gloves on and what I'm
going to do is just clean you up really
good now what do you use to clean up
after you're done right now we're just
cleaning up any kind of blood that might
be left and then since we have already
done the cleaning part before we don't
need to do necessarily another set of
cleaning what I'm going to do is I'm
going to use some essential oils so we
stay in the natural world of things
these essential oils have black seed oil
in it
it has olive oil coconut oil almond oil
a clip this oil tea tree oil big Montoya
and some of the other essential oils
that act as antiseptic antibacterial as
well as it gives soothing to the skin it
also gives soothing to the muscles as
well so this is all natural it is all
natural we try not to use anything that
is not natural that's the way to go and
then there's health benefits that are
mentioned in the Sunnah for using black
seeds so we incorporate that as well
so now that we are done with the
procedure of magenta one of the things
we will do is this was the scalpel that
we use we're going to make sure that we
dispose of it properly and responsibly
any kind of blood that we have removed
and the cups is properly discarded and
is picked up by a healthcare waste
management company and is discarded in a
responsible way
so brother Eddie how are you feeling all
right I'm going to cover you up a little
bit and you are ready to get up just get
up a little slow okay and just sit down
all right that's another thing is like
if you can incorporate not only this
enough but if you want to take a cinema
nap this is a great place on this table
to take that soon a nap is very very
comfortable it's very relaxing so you
can come and have a pajama session and
we implement a major Sunnah in your life
and also take a soon to nap what we want
to do now is make sure you're hydrated
Africa Java so let me give you some
water and while we're in the path of
adopting sand I also want to give you
some honey with black seed in it for you
to take right now I just I can't express
how much I love that look at what is
this now it's all natural that's the
thing nothing toxic you see this is this
is honey with black seed just suck it up
honey I'm a black seed mashallah
bismillah open it more is coming up no
just you just push it from the bottom
hmm and this hydrate yourself and some
water this is great stuff I'm telling
you and Islam is the natural way and
this is another part of that that we're
missing out on we're trying to revive
this bismillah
it's quite different from if you're you
know I guess certain drugs have their
place but we I you know I try to avoid
any and all but these are these are
toxins coming in the body this is like
you know like he was saying this is
something that doesn't hurt it's a
painless pain-free and afterwards you
feel good you you know you you you get
rewarded this isn't actually a bother
let's talk about that for a second
before we cut out because this is the
when you do this with the right
intention you all sorted by a loss one
time there right it is perfect yet is it
yeah it is exactly right so you're only
getting the health benefits but you're
also adopting its enough at a time for
this one that is not necessarily as
popular has adopted prophet sallallaahu
dorsum said that there's an increased
reward for people or for soon not to be
adopted the ones that are not as popular
as adopted thank you very much you're
welcome
so the I became hum didn't I you know I
I'm happy to have come and I just want
to motivate people to really make this a
part of their life this is something I
think that also for for myself way back
when I also didn't know about it when I
investigated it like anything I'm gonna
incorporate in my life I mean you know
something that you know you don't know
much about you do some research you look
into it I read abundance of hadith and
it wasn't you mentioned one honey but
there are abundance of hadith and I
thought this is something that the
process of some was doing was this was
like a stress and he really it's not
like this is something that it is is a
is a benefit that we're preventing from
reaching us and we don't implement it
right can you elaborate on the amount of
hadith they're out there on this and why
and people have been in this kind of way
yeah I think for the long time this had
this this practice of pajama has not has
not been as accepted because of the
hygiene practices and from because of
the modern medicine and drugs that have
kind of taken over the health care and
Islamic medicine kind of went in the
back burner for a bit but you can see
the benefits of pajama when people get
Hazama
the benefits they see prophets Allah
loves someone numerous occasion
elaborated and emphasized do hey Jemma
knew hey Jemma somebody came and said o
prophet of Allah I have headache
he said do pajama somebody came and says
I don't have damage intellect prophet
soul awesome said no hey JAMA and if
that was not enough when Prophet SAW
Allah has loved one and SL Mehran and as
he was coming down the angels of the
Prophet the angels of the heaven said o
prophet of Allah upon you upon your own
marijana and then he comes down and the
angel says o prophet of Allah upon your
on miyajima that is the testimony of the
importance of [ __ ] Ahmad now see here's
the thing Allah subhana WA Ta'ala
created this body and when he created
this body he knows exactly what is up
with his body so he educated Prophet
sallallahu wasallam to tell us if you
want to be cured if you want remedy for
any illnesses your pajama take honey
your pajama take honey and make sure
that we are also incorporating things
that sort of Fatiha for Shiva because
that's another thing prophet of Allah
Islam has emphasized on and then when
you do that investigation and do that
research and you finally come and do a
JAMA and you see that quality of blood
that toxic coming out of your body and
you say Subhan Allah
well lie a lot so kind of what the other
prophets of the Lawson is how this kill
our my body that no other no other
treatment no other procedure can
physically take this toxic blood out of
the body other than some people might
think of bloodletting or blood donation
but believe me if the Red Cross was
taking this kind of blood out of the
body they won't want to do anything with
this blood yeah so they taking a good
blood which has its own merits and
benefits right but this is bad
yuck disgusting blood physically coming
out of your wife yeah along with
building a healthy body you know
obviously we have the spiritual side you
have so many benefits and
in prayer you know just living in slum
which is a natural way of life you know
and then when we go on to the other part
that's not left out nutrition you know
building a healthy body based on eating
real food you know good nutritious foods
nowadays you have a lot of process for
fine you know foods that are just really
great wrecking havoc on the body so
having good nutrition and then exercise
and now incorporating things like this
into your life or as opposed to you know
I was one of those guilty of that I
thought okay there's a pill for every
ill alright cuz you know you have the
for anybody before when if you'd watch a
commercial you may have a ton I mean the
pharmaceutical company is just pushing
these drugs left and right which are
toxic and many of them have 15 16 20 30
different side effects I remember Vioxx
I don't know if you heard of aya right
right and I used to take Vioxx for the
back yes
and they actually there was a big fight
to get it off on the market but I
believe last time I checked and I looked
into it fifty thousand people died but
maker mark agreed to pay a nine hundred
fifty million dollar fine to settle
claims that it marketed by ox as a
treatment for rheumatoid arthritis
before receiving FDA approval to do so
the company will also plead guilty to
misdemeanor charges try ox was pulled
off the market in 2004 evidence showed
that it increased the risk of heart
attacks and strokes when Vioxx was first
approved by the FDA in May of 1999
consumers were ecstatic at the prospect
of getting their lives back intended to
treat osteoarthritic menstrual and acute
pain in adults
Vioxx was designed to be a safer
painkiller compared to its alternatives
with average annual sales of 2.5 million
dollars Merrick's newest drug quickly
became a blockbuster in just 2003 alone
Vioxx sales accounted for 11 percent of
Marek's revenue that year but little did
anyone know what Gasca was about two and
four
on September 30 2004 Marik voluntarily
ordered a withdrawal of ions from the
market after studies showed a double
increase of heart attack and stroke in
patients approximately 20 million people
around the world had been taken by
office it is further estimated this drug
caused at least 50,000 deaths imported
there can you imagine that Wow
you know 50,000 that's what kind of war
went on there you finally you know so
these are those drugs that are up there
so I try to really bring to the
forefront people reviving the Sunnah you
know from how we eat to how we live and
this is just one of those things that if
we can implement along with the others
because you can't just be eating all
sorts of garbage and junk and whatnot
and you know think this is going to be a
miracle particular it's incorporating
everything everything I mean even from
eating perspective if you just look at
the hadith the Prophet SAW Allah us no
more prophets all of them said eat one
third drink one third and leave one
third empty right so but prophet salah
salem knew what is to come in the future
people are going to take in toxins it's
almost inevitable to to not take toxins
we have toxins in the air some of our
water qualities and about that we have
toxins so profits of a loss and give us
a cure then when that happens this is
the cure you want it when you have
headache this is the cure when you have
blood pressure this is the cure you want
to take a from the lie you know people
continue to surprise me when they come
back and tell me different benefits that
they have had with a gentleman one
person recently came and he said that
he's able to see a lot better a funny
story is somebody came and he said that
after I had pajama done I started seeing
a little blurry and that really scared
me so I said go see a doctor so when he
went to see the doctor he said the
reason you seem gonna blur is your
glasses are not overpowered your
eyesight has actually gotten better and
he he had to lower his number on the
glasses I'm not sure what's going or not
but that was a surprise even to me
one lady like I said she came in in the
middle of February was minus 10 degrees
she
came in and she had no jacket on just
wearing a t-shirt and as his sister no
jacket is snowing outside
she said brother father I can't meet
wear a jacket because with the collar of
the jacket touches my neck it triggers
my head it's so bad that she takes Botox
shots on her head to get rid of the
headaches and saw her after two three
months of doing hijama a couple times
and I said what are we doing we're doing
headache he's young again she's like no
I think it's gone and I was like I'm
sorry did you not forgive you a
different pill she said no I haven't
seen my doctor in a very long time now
and in my headache is gone from her
gentleman so this is just a testimony of
the the truth and the hub that is in the
other things of prophets of Allah Islam
and that's the main thing now if this
was something that is passed down for
some ancient tradition that now didn't
have no connection to Islam or what not
and you're like okay guessing is it good
is it not and what you know because it's
not part of the standard medical care
system what Trump saw that is that we
keep saying the Prophet Muhammad SAW so
so this is divinely sent to him from the
creator of the heavens and earth to him
being the last and final messenger that
trumps all day and these are authentic
hadith these are authentic hadith sahih
hadith the Hadees that talks about that
pajama gives you better intellect pyjama
gives you better digestion a gentleman
gives you better pal these are all
authentic hadees all right so I hope you
guys are convinced to incorporate this
into your lifestyle again you can go
ahead and weigh it out you can you know
like many toxic things that are out
there that we put in our body you know
with so many different side effects
versus you have a way here which really
painless pain-free I didn't feel any
pain you can take a little sooner nap
right you're more actually efficient in
the day when you take a little like 20
30 minute nap hour and a half they call
it and then you implement it as soon
that you get reward it's a win-win
across the board
hundred percent when went across the
board so no paint no any side effects um
the only thing is that you might feel a
little irritation in your skin because
of the dry weather and things
that's why we put some oil on we Hum Dil
I have not had anybody who came back and
said that after I defeat John Monnett
this happened I guess but since there is
a cut there's a chance of getting
infection so you want to make sure that
you keep it clean you wash it properly
and keep it clean there's no need for
you to put any bandages on just let it
air dry and leather plants naturally
okay so if people are in heat in the
Chicago area they can come visit you
wherever how can they find you hook up
with you yeah so just go to WWE core hey
Gemma calm we have an app on your
Android and Apple iPhone as well just
look for an app called Chicago hijama
you can do a lot of research in Chicago
Kujawa comm one thing I will tell all
your viewers is that there's a lot of
information out there and there's a lot
of YouTube videos out there
unfortunately in certain areas a JAMA is
being practiced in a non professional
manner however especially in the United
States or our place we do it in a very
very professional manner our
practitioners are all certified and some
of them are licensed as well we do it in
a very hygienic manner here don't get
scared by looking at those videos some
of those videos can be really scary
alhamdulillah
that's why brother Eddie wanted to show
you guys firsthand what happens on how a
JAMA is done pick a step take a step
take a leap of faith a little bit you
want to do research our website has a
bunch of information on it ww Chicago
hajima calm we have male practitioners
and female practice practitioners here
can help you so even if you're maybe
making a pit stop Chicago you visit
Devon day or whatever you mean
appointment you know make it a family
affair stop in what about someone who is
in a rural area they don't plan on
visiting Chicago there's no place like
this out there is there any workshop
something that someone can do maybe
someone's a chiropractor maybe a medical
man are Tichenor and they want to
incorporate this into their private
practice or you know someone wants to do
some workshops do you guys have any
video anything
you travel and do seminars or there are
some trainings available out there we
don't necessarily train people were not
certified to train but I would encourage
any chiropractor that's out there
acupuncture's that are out there are
medical doctors to start and incorporate
this in their practice any assistance
they would need we were happy to help
them with that so they can do that they
can do that and we're here to support
yeah okay well that's it this is the hot
JAMA session with me being the the
person having it done it was great I'm
telling you stop in here check it out
look into it look at all the benefits
revive this Sunnah thank you guys thank
you very much as I'm like oh how you
doing dr. Z how do you say your last
name cuz I hit a lot late a lot so your
attending doctor yes internal medicine
attending doctor okay so you are
familiar with Ujamaa
yeah I had the opportunity to lay down
low with [ __ ] fahadh not more than a
couple months ago yeah how was that
experience was very rejuvenating you
know it helps the circulation helps to
relieve some muscle aches and pains that
I was experiencing I'm into fitness a
lot of working out and sometimes you get
to injuries and poles and things like
that so I found it really rejuvenating
and not to mention this one aspect of it
as well
yeah it's definitely beneficial now it's
kind of it's it's kind of nice to hear a
medical doctor having nice things to say
because it's not part of the the
standard of care in jauntily right I
mean the Western medicine you know it's
if there's a big divide between Eastern
and Western medicine but all branches of
medicine are respected it's just
basically it's just like the Big Brother
type of thing you know they don't accept
it openly but there is definitely a lot
of you know merit to it
the reason why is you know a lot of the
big medical schools are run you know
their weight and a lot of money involved
in it so lately there's been more of a
opening awakening to doctors and
osteopathic medicine and other types of
medicine that help the helped heal the
body in different ways rather than just
giving pills to people so definitely
gets into the nitty-gritty of it or
getting into more of a physical medicine
aspect I like what you just said so just
giving pills to people yes yes I'm not
the last thing I try to do is treat with
pills they're not really I mean this is
just chemicals and pharmaceuticals stuff
obviously there's benefit when when
there's major issues but when we have
small ailments and muscle aches and
pains there's a lot of different things
that we can try instead of just
medicating and treating all the time
what else what else can you tell us
about the high drama that you've
acquired the knowledge you've acquired
about it well as far as Ujamaa
you know it's it's been it's like a
reverse massage instead of you know
everybody knows that a massage feels
good when you you know loosen the muscle
tissues and things like tightness so and
so this is basically the reverse of it
it pulls the skin up gives you some
suction and allows the blood increases
blood flow it's gonna be beneficial in
many elements high blood pressure
migraines
also in rheumatic diseases there's some
there's some benefit to all so romantic
diseases as well so a lot of a lot of
medical benefits definitely this is
coming from a medical doctor telling us
these things so it's great to hear that
from you what other advice can you give
us so you had the you mentioned the
drugs which many of our toxic right yes
yes the side effects yes you know
there's there's a lot of medicines that
may seem harmless but take a good amount
of it and will kill you like if you can
aspirin is beneficial when somebody's
having a heart attack correct it it
inhibits the platelets from clumping but
if you take 20 advanced means then you
know you'll die yeah so these all have a
toxic effect and
you know fortunately there are other
means of trying to treat things but
definitely you know do talk to your
doctor before you stop any medicines
this is not any medical advice for
anybody but there is a limitation to all
kinds of medications for example also in
non-steroidal anti-inflammatories like
ibuprofen we'll leave these over the
kind of things a lot of people coming to
my hospital all the time saying hey I
have dark stools because they can cause
bleeding in the gut so treating elements
just with the medicinal way is one
aspect but another aspect is you know
looking at all the other alternatives to
medicine as well and some of it and as a
doctor as doctors out there you take the
what is the Hippocratic oath Hippocratic
oath correct exactly no harm do no harm
do no harm yeah so this way it's very
specific and you have to be very careful
when you're treating individuals that
you're not going to cause this person
harm so my big advice to all my patients
is always be discerning what you're
taking don't just take your randomly do
not take mint medicines just because you
feel like taking it always that there's
always some sort of benefit and and the
inverse relationship is always some sort
of harm when it's not taken properly or
taking too much so we got a thumbs up
for the jumper thumbs up absolutely I'm
also a customer or probably you know
recipient of a gentleman so a lot you
know it's it's it's a lot of benefits
thank you thank you very much
absolutely our disease being a good news
show thank you so much thank you thank
you get on the hijab oh you hear that
absolutely all right so I call it my
thumb so if people come in you're one of
the people that they'll meet here and
greet you agree done with a nice big
smile what's your name
my name is saya saya come seaside at the
front at Chicago hijama that's nice a
little waiting area beautiful that was
my session of hamdulillah
I'm telling you get up on the high drama
let's revive this
tell me what we try it tell more people
about it and inshallah we can revive
this lost Cigna you follow me if you in
Chicago stop and check them out here at
the Chicago JAMA do your research check
it out and you'll see tremendous
benefits I really recommend we had a
doctor testified to it medical
practitioners should take the lead on
this incorporate this instead of just
pushing like you know the doctor was
saying drugs drugs drugs with all these
different side effects everything has
their time in place and then
incorporating these practices from the
center crack natural means do no harm
you know have Hippocratic oath you know
the the path that's going to lead to the
least amount of harm for the patient so
chiropractors doctors look to
incorporate this and many of the other
natural means that are out there and
inshallah we can make a difference
subscribe if you haven't already see you
Sonic